previously on Deadpool I love you way
too awesome
we can fight this you're right
cancers only my liver lungs prostate and
brain all things I can live without what
a dude tries to make you a super slave
and kidnaps your future baby mama I
played a lot of roles stands alone
distress ain't one of us it's time to be
a superhero
so case I'd be happy to sit on there all
caught up
[Music]
oh you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care
stronk eyes
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in a
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you missed me read
what in the ass
my name's cable here for the kid what
the kid mover guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be you need you lot smarter
than I look
hey let cable kill this kid but I can't
do this alone we're gonna form a super
duper group that's what we're gonna do
our group will be forward-thinking
gender neutral it will be known as
x-force a little derivative you're
absolutely right now cue the music don't
call it a comeback
breakdown
tell me they got that in slow motion
doing the right thing is messy
[Applause]
you want to fight for what's right
sometime you have to fight dirty
that is why the man bun is just a
millennial mullet oh god I wish I
finished college he lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it hey everybody its charlie
we got a new Deadpool extended trailer
with some new shots will break down and
that Donald Glover situation from this
morning where he leaked a script that
was supposed to the finale script from
the Deadpool TV series that had been
cancelled recently so I'll explain
what's going on with that it's not quite
what you think but based on what Donald
Glover is saying it's marvel that
cancelled the TV series not FX networks
who's already working with Donald Glover
so don't worry I'll explain what's going
on
it is fascinating in Grand harmontown
tradition he went on that tear this
morning the student has become the
master I love Dan Harmon's response to
that - he was just saying that I'm not
sure that that master was ever a student
say that he's always worshipped Donald
Glover's work so everybody seems to be
in Donald Glover's camp on this Deadpool
TV serious situation but if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's crazy infinity war coming up and
Deadpool - the new stuff from this
extended Deadpool trailer just him
recapping the events of the first film
you see more of those hits that he goes
on during the montage and that last big
trailer like when he's hitting what
looks like the Yakuza here he busts it
in through the window they might be
doing their version of that Dark Knight
China scene where Batman flies into the
window and then takes off with one of
them but you get a little more of the
supporting cast a little more of blind
al you get a little bit more of this
stripper pole scene where he's in the
club going after what looks like some
kind of biker gang this might be their
Magic Mike parody scene because he comes
out with stripper heels on but we get a
little more of Julie and Denison's
character a little bit more of cable vs
Deadpool like you see him come up and
whack him with this big crowbar the
thing about Julie & Denison is that a
lot of people are wondering if he
actually might be a young version of
black Tom Cassidy because for a long
time last year there was a rumor that
that character was going to be the main
villain of Deadpool - but because cables
coming back in time to kill someone
cable is a hero he's not a villain why
would he come back to kill a kid unless
that
was gonna grow up to be someone really
terrible the plot of the trailer that
we've seen so far like what we know of
it lends some more credence to that but
there's no confirmation still wide open
to speculation you guys can let me know
do you actually think that he's playing
a young version of black Tom Cassidy but
if he is there would be a slight change
to his powers because it looks like he's
giving off heat blast some sort of
explosion here with all these cop cars
Tom Cassidy from the comics has Groot
like powers he has plant manipulation he
can give off concussive blasts with the
wood that he grows from himself so I'm
assuming whatever they did they changed
the comic book origin just a little bit
to serve the story which I'm totally
fine with black Tom Cassidy very minor
comic book villain but he did show up in
that very first Deadpool limited series
during the mid-90s new shot of him
spinning his head around on his
shoulders him getting ready to engage
these troops here and then a wider shot
of him in that really dirty looking
Deadpool suit going up to recruit the
x-force members but on that point a lot
of people were asking me if this suit is
an Easter Egg for the Deadpool x-force
suit
it might take away from this is that no
they're not going for that it's just a
dirty version of his red costume he just
got blown up so there's just dust all
over it so the colors are really muted
and on top of that whoever color timed
the movie tuned the colors way down so
that everything looks kind of turquoise
and that's what's causing the suit to
look a slightly different color they
actually already did the white x-force
suit back during the first movie before
he got the red suit that was what that
janky white suit he was running around
in was an Easter Egg for that was like
them doing their version of the uncanny
x-force suit
so if you're not a big comic book reader
there are a couple different versions of
Deadpool's costume
there's his x-men variant that he wore
for a little while there's the white one
that everyone's talking about that's
from uncanny x-force number one there's
an evil Deadpool variant and then
there's just a regular red costume that
he normally wears but on to the main
event Donald Glover vs. Marvel
television so if you don't know what's
going on Marvel was gonna do an adult
animation Deadpool series at FXX so when
Marvel took the show to FX they're like
okay great we have this awesome talented
person Donald Glover who's blowing it up
winning all kinds of awards with his
Atlanta series let's put him on board
that was announced early last year cut
to a couple days ago Marvel says that we
have mutually decided to part ways with
FX it was basically the network's saying
that they were canceling the show before
it started it had already been greenlit
for a 10 episode run meaning that there
wasn't a pilot or anything like that
like they just bought 10 episodes of a
Deadpool TV series so they started
writing it and then you know come to
find out when we learned a little bit
about what was going on behind the
scenes they said there were creative
differences now based on what Donald
Glover was tweeting this morning we
learned what those creative differences
were so because FX networks does such
really weird TV and they love Donald
Glover so much it sounds like Marvel
television were the people not
comfortable with the version of Deadpool
that Donald Glover was trying to do the
script that he tweeted out this morning
for the final episode isn't for in
actual episode it's more of a meta
commentary about why the show was
canceled or why he thinks that it was
canceled but the long and short of it is
is that Marvel TV saw what he was doing
and even though he's a great writer they
didn't want that version of Deadpool
which is why they took the project away
from FX meaning that they might
resurrect it on the Disney streaming
service they'll still probably do an
animated Deadpool TV series somewhere we
just don't know when that's gonna happen
where it's gonna happen who's gonna be
involved with it but Deadpool is a cash
cow eventually you'll see it somewhere
in some form probably the best way to
describe Marvel's objections in Donald
lovers eyes based on his commentary is
that they thought that his writing
in his references because Deadpool makes
a lot of references he takes shots at a
lot of things that are happening in real
life
marble thought that his references were
too specific and it sounded like the
scripts were really political like he
was taking a lot of shots at Trump and
the president things that Marvel was not
comfortable with him doing with the
character so if you're really mad that
there's no Deadpool TV series really
Marvel TV or the people to blame in this
just because they didn't want to take a
shot on donald glover even though it
probably would have been a weird version
of Deadpool it still probably would have
been pretty cool but at least we have
the film series they'll resurrect the
project somewhere at some other studio
on a different network probably on their
streaming platform we could talk all day
about it but just leave all your
questions in the comments below if
you're not really sure what's going on
with the TV series or what's going on
with the movies either there'll be new
Marvel later this week but I am seeing
ready player one tonight so I'll post a
non-spoilery review tomorrow I'm also
doing a new episode of Krypton so whole
bunch of stuff coming tomorrow while you
wait for everything click here for that
new Iron Man bleeding-edge armor and
Finity war trailer and click here for
that other Deadpool trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]